there's been a big turnout for early
voting in the US with long lines many
polling stations like this one in Los
Angeles County but one group was
noticeably absent as many election
volunteers noticed I hadn't seen a lot
of Latinos today that's come as a
surprise since one Latin American issue
has played a big role in the campaign
the migrants making their way to the US
Mexican border from Central America
President Trump has put the issue of
illegal migration at the forefront of
his campaigning for the Republicans
blaming the Democrats for allowing them
into the United States Democrats hoped
to turn Latino discontent over Trump's
migration rhetoric into votes but they
don't have a detailed strategy for the
diverse Latino community according to
Sonia Diaz the head of a Latino
think-tank almost 60 percent of Latinos
surveyed in a national poll had not
received any sort of communication
information from a candidate Latino
interest groups are trying to fill the
void main' II such as the immigrants
rights organization cheela in Los
Angeles have set up call centers
volunteers have translated voter guides
and are reaching out to potential voters
sex out of ten Latinos are Millennials
and many are voting for the first time
the latest polls have shown that less
than half of them know who's running in
their respective districts with the
political rhetoric high and a growing
distrust in the government and its
institutions many have simply tuned out
I'm Nessa Cindy Trump the Trump
administration has had a very negative
effect on the way Latinos view the
elections because we now believe that
our vote doesn't count or it's not going
to affect the administration Kevin de
Leon is a Democratic candidate for
Senator he's been one of the most
visible of all of the Latino candidates
in California and he's been urging
Democrats to articulate a position
beyond stop Trump during a campaign
rally at his favorite taco vendor
DeLeon Colden Latinos to vote for his
fellow Democrats to help win back the
House of Representatives it's critical
and these very dangerous cuts went two
times in our nation's history
engage in a battle for the soul of our
nation against a president without one
that the Latino vote comes out strong
you know come Tuesday November 6 to send
a very clear message that were one
American Latino voters represent one of
the fastest-growing demographics in the
United States
this year's midterms may indicate
whether the Democrats have found the key
to mobilizing them at the polls